COMMITTEE OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT- HEARING TODAY.
THANKS FOR JOINING US I'M
LOOKING FOR TO PRODUCTIVE
HEARING WITH MY GOOD FRIEND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS EARLIER
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT CAL EXPO
WHICH WAS BEING USED AS A
COPING NINETEEN VACCINATION
VACCINATION AND TESTING THOUGHT.
BEFORE MY OPENING REMARKS LET
ME REMIND EVERYONE OF THE
GROUND RULES FOR TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. AS YOU
KNOW DUE TO COVER NINETEEN WE
HAVE LIMITED ROOM AVAILABLE IN
THE CHAIRMAN IN THE CAPITAL.
PLEASE REMIND FOR THE MASS
REQUIREMENT WHERE YOU'RE IN
HERE AND MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING.
NUMBER. 1-877-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO
VISIT THE COMPANY WEBSITE AT I.
S. M. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. AT THE END OF THE HEARING
WILL HAVE TIME FOR LIMITED
PUBLIC COMMENT ASSEMBLY ROLE.
IS TO ENSURE THAT WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT
HEARING WE SEEK TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED. IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO WE CAN
HAVE AN EFFECT OF DELIBERATION
AND DISCUSSIONS. ON THE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THESE GOALS. WE WILL
NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS.
HISTORICALLY COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS
ARE PROVIDED A VARIETY OF
DISASTER RELATED FUNCTIONS.
INCLUDING BASS COMES FOR
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS
STAGING. SITES FOR MUTUAL AID
RESOURCES AND UTILITY
RESTORATIONS AS WELL AS SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDERS. THROUGHOUT THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
FAIRGROUNDS HAVE ALSO BEEN A
CENTRAL EXPANDING VACCINE AND
TESTING SITES FOR GROUNDS HAVE
ALSO BEEN USED TO SHELTER THE
HOMELESS AND HOUSE MIGRANT
CHILDREN. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS HAD A MAJOR IMPACT
ON THE FISCAL OPERATION THE FOR
GROUNDS. AS ALMOST EVERY MAJOR
EVENTS WERE COUNSELED IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND ARE STILL
UNCERTAINTY AS FOR THE
REMAINDER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FOR EXAMPLE CAL EXPO IN
SACRAMENTO DEL MAR IN SAN
DIEGO. AND LAKE FAIRGROUNDS IN
LAKE COUNTY HAVE REPORTED
FINANCIAL CUTS. AND LAYOFFS AND
EVEN HAVE BECOME GO SITES TO GO
SITE FOR TESTING AND ACTION.
GIVEN THE DROP CALIFORNIA'S
RISK OF MAJOR FARMING TYING.
HELLO ALREADY SEEMS. WILDFIRE
ACTIVE. SO FAR THIS YEAR THE
BILL. OVER TO THE THREE FORTY
FIVE DOLLARS AND FORTY THOUSAND
FORTY ACRES DESTROYED THIS AN
INCREASE OF. TWELVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR FIRES AND ELEVEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
THREE ACRES FROM LAST YEAR.
OVER THE PAST WEEK OR- OVER TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY NEW WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX WERE WORTH IN
CALIFORNIA JURISDICTION. AS I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
OUR PALACE ON. HOW PREPARED ARE
PROGRAMS TO HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIA RESPOND TO MAJOR
DISASTERS. LESSONS LEARNED FROM
PREVIOUS INCIDENTS AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE
OUR FOR HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE AND
JOINT COMMITTEE ON FARES
ALLOCATIONS AND CLASSIFICATIONS
FOR HIS OPENING REMARKS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. WALA
THANK YOU SHARE RODRIGUEZ AND-
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN AND WORK IN THE
CRITICAL AREA OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND NOT ONLY AS
CHAIR OF. THE COMMITTEE BUT AS
A FORMER FIRST RESPONDER- AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU AND
I SHARE IN COMMON IS. I SPENT
NEARLY SIX YEARS AS A PAID CALL
FIREFIGHTER AND- A REGISTERED-
EMERGENCY MEDICAL. TECHNICIAN
OR AN EMT- AND SO I WANT TO OUR
CALL ALL WHO HAVE JOINED US
HERE THIS AFTERNOON FOR THIS
HEARING. I LIKE TO THINK OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FROM BOTH
AGRICULTURE AND EMERGENCY-
SOME- THE MANAGEMENT FOR THEIR
PART IN HELPING PLAN TO PREPARE
FOR THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING
YOU KNOW AGAIN I LIKE TO THINK
CHEN RODRIGUEZ FOR. ENGAGING
THE ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE AND
THE JOINT- COMMITTEE ON FARES
ALLOCATIONS AND CLASSIFICATION.
A TO HAVE A DISCUSSION TO LEARN
ABOUT THE CRITICAL ROLE OF
FAIRGROUNDS IN CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM. MOST
OF US THE FAIRGROUNDS PRIMARILY
AS SITES FOR ANNUAL FAIRS AND
SOME OTHER WELL KNOWN SEASONAL
VENUES SUCH AS ENTERTAINMENT IN
SOME COMPETITIONS INCLUDING
HORSE RACING CAR RACING OR-
RODEOS- HOWEVER AS THE IMPACT
OF SOME DISASTERS HAVE BECOME
MORE EXTENSIVE IN COMMON HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS CLEAR THAT
FAIRGROUND LOCATIONS ALL
SEVENTY SIX OF THEM. ARE IN THE
CENTRAL PART OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
RAPIDLY AND EFFECTIVELY
RESPOND- AMID TIMES OF NATURAL
DISASTERS AND PUBLIC
EMERGENCIES. AS WE ALL KNOW
TWENTY TWENTY WAS THE LARGEST
MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE
SEASON RECORDED IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. WITH THREE FOURTHS OF
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING EXTREME DROUGHT
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILDFIRE
SEASON MAY BE JUST AS LARGE AND
DESTRUCTIVE AS LAST YEAR. AND
IN ADDITION TO BEING CRITICAL
SITES FOR OUR STATE'S WILDFIRE
RESPONSE. FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS CALIFORNIA'S VERY
GROUNDS HAVE ALSO SERVICE COVER
NINETEEN TESTING CENTERS
VACCINATION SITES SITES FOR
CAL- YES COMMAND CENTERS AND
SITES FOR HOMELESS SHELTERS. AS
SUCH WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIA'S BACKGROUNDS ARE
PROPERLY PREPARED TO HANDLE THE%
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON AND OTHER-
SOME DISASTERS THAT MAY HAPPEN
AND OCCUR AGAIN THANK YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALSO JUST
WANTED TO OPEN UP TO ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES AND
WHAT DO YOU LIKE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DIRECTORY DO YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS RODRIGUEZ AND RIVAS FOR
HOLDING ENJOYING MEETING- FOR
AND FOR THE PANELISTS ON
INFORMING US ON ONE OF IF NOT
THE MOST RELEVANT. ISSUES.
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACING TODAY.
GROUNDS ARE A GREAT WAY TO THE
CAN. TOGETHER BUT HAVE GROWN TO
BE A CRITICAL. DURING TIME OF
EMERGENCY. WE HAVE SEEN HOW
CRITICAL CONNECTIVITY CAPACITY
IS IN THE TIMES OF EMERGENCIES
INCLUDING DURING THE STATE'S
RECENT DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
THE ACCELERATED NEED FOR
BROADBAND PARTICULARLY AT A
REAL SIDES POISED TO ASSIST IN
AN EMERGENCY CANNOT BE IGNORED.
I HOPE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT HOW
TO KEEP FOLKS CONNECTED DURING
THE MOST STRESSFUL TIMES OF THE
YEAR OF THEIR LIVES. INVESTING
IN FIBRE MIDDLE MILE WILL
INCREASE SPEEDS AND
ACCESSIBILITY FOR HOUSEHOLD THE
COMMUNITY ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS FAIRGROUNDS. ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET CONNECTIVITY IS
ONLY ONE PART OF AN EQUATION
THE DOES NOT WORK WITHOUT
CONTINUED AFFORDABLE INTERNET
SERVICE OFFERINGS ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE IN A RURAL DISTRICTS.
AND I WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT
IT'S A I'M HONORED THAT- THE-
MAY REVISE HAS BROUGHT UP OF
PROXY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS BROADBAND IN WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP OF THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY. WE HOPEFULLY WE
CAN MOVE THIS FORWARD AND.
BENEFIT OUR FAIRGROUNDS THANK
YOU. IN THE COURSE OF SOMEONE
SARDAR VICE. TO MANAGE. THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS YEAR A- THE IMPORTANCE OF.
IN OVER DESIGN MAN IS A
IMPORTANT FOR. US IS
LEGISLATORS TO. TO KEEP IN
MIND. IT IS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ESPECIALLY
DURING A FIRE OF WHICH I GUESS
THERE IS ONE NOW IN MY
DISTRICT. AND ESPECIALLY FOR
EVACUATION PURPOSES THEY HAVE
ALL OF THE- FACILITIES NEEDED
TO MAKE THE ADJUSTMENTS FOR
WHATEVER THE DISASTER IS. AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
STAY ON TOP OF THIS ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE THE SPEAKERS TAKING
TIME TODAY ON THE PANEL. TO YOU
TO GIVE US AN UPDATE ON ON WHAT
THE STATUS IS AND WHAT OUR
NEEDS ARE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OF. MEMBER MATHIS VICE
CHAIR OF AGRICULTURE HELD A
QUESTION CALM DOWN. COMMENT
THANK YOU CHIU IS ALSO TO THANK
THE PANELS TODAY- AND FOR THE
BODY TO TAKE TIME TO HAVE THIS
HEARING AND WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING THESE MATTERS-
FRYING- AT LEAST MY TENURE.
HERE AT THE BUILDING. AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
COMES OUT OF IT AND LOOKING IN-
EVEN MORE FAVORABLY TO ACTUALLY
SEE SOME. ITEMS IN TE BUDGET
THE ISSUE THAT WILL HELP
IMPROVE- THING IT WOULD BE NICE
TO ACTUALLY SEE INSTEAD OF JUST
TALKING ACTUALLY SEE THE MONEY
GOING TO WORK WE KNOW IT NEEDS
TO GO. TO SEE IMPROVEMENTS OF
OUR FAIRGROUNDS AS WE KNOW FIRE
DROUGHT WHICH WERE GOING INTO
BOTH THIS YEAR- THERE'S THINGS
THEY NEED TO GET BUILT OUT
THERE'S FUNDING THEY NEED TO
GET THERE. AND I REALLY HOPE
THAT THE REST OF OUR BODY-
TAKES THE HEART WHAT IS SAID
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU. OKAY
WITHOUT WILL GO AHEAD AND START.
SO SCHOOL THE FIRST PANEL AS RE.
OF PLEASE KEEP. YOUR COMMENTS
TO LESS. THAN A TEN. ALSO MA'AM
WILL HOLD QUITE. INTO THE END
OF EACH PRESENT. AND PANELS
FIRST WE'LL HEAR FROM. MEDICAL
RICH. W. TO. A GOVERNORS ALL OF.
SERVICES- MITCH ARE YOU THERE.
HELLO THANK YOU AFTERNOON AND-
YOU- CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I AM MUCH
BETTER I AM. DEBBIE DRY HERE AT
KALAYAAN. AND IT'S PLEASURE TO
TEST- WE DO- ON THE IMPORTANCE
THAT. OP PLAY EMERGENCIES
RECALL. I'M SINCE TO THE
THIRTEEN- CAN SAID FIFTEEN
PRESENT MAY DISASTER
DECLARATIONS- YOU KNOW TO
QUALIFY AT THE STAFF LEVEL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- THE
CORRELATES TO NEARLY FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND DESTRUCTION
SO WHEN WE HAVE THOSE TYPES THE
LEVEL OF DISASTERS- THE USE OF
FOR TEMPORARY TEMPORARY
RELOCATING. UP CLOSE TO A SAFE
LOCATION- COMES UP TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AND- FAIRGROUNDS
HAVE PROVEN TO BE THAT- THAT
HAVEN FOR US- DUE TO THE UNIQUE
QUALITIES OF THOSE FAIRGROUNDS-
THEY AREN'T NAY NOT ONLY SERVE
AS AN EXCELLENT SITE FOR
SHELTERING PEOPLE AND ANIMALS-
BUT WE'D WATCH THEM MATURE TO
BECOME CRITICAL LOCATIONS FOR
US FOR LOGISTICAL HUBS. ARE
BERMAN SHE RESPONSE OPERATIONS
I WILL USE THEM AS BASE CAMPS-
USER MISSTATING AREAS OF DEBRIS
SUPPORTING. AND EVEN LONG TERM
HOUSING SO- THERE ARE MULTIPLE
MISSIONS- THAT THE- PROGRAMS
ARE PERFORMED PRO STRING.
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY. THE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS LOTS OF SPACE-
HAVE THE STILL THEIR PARKING AT.
WATER POWER AND SEWER- MAKE
THEM IDEAL LOCATIONS COUPLE
THAT WITH THE- FACT THAT
EVERYBODY IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
LOCATIONS- AND THAT MAKES THEM.
ARE VERY WELL SUITED FOR THESE
NEEDS. DURING ACTIVATIONS WE
AMPLIFY THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE THESE SITES BY
BRINGING IN GOLF CARTS OR ADA
RESTROOMS FOR EXAMPLE FOR- OR
EIGHTY EIGHT ARE THOSE NEEDING
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
ASSISTANCE SOMETIMES LAUNDRY
FACILITIES EXTRA CITING
ASSIGNING AND SIGNAGE-
LIGHTING- SECURITY EXCEPT RUN
SO WE HAVE PROVIDED A FAIR
GROUNDS TO MAKE THEM EVEN MORE
ROBUST- TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
BECAUSE THE FOR ARE ARE MANAGED
BY OUR STATE PARTNERS IT THE-
IS THAT I CAN CALL THEM AT ALL
HOURS AND- WE USE THAT AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT- IN EVENINGS
AND AFTER HOURS WHERE- WHEN WE
USE COMMERCIAL SITES THEY'RE
NOT NEARLY AS RESPONSIVE. AND
CAN BE AVAILABLE TO US AND SO-
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL- ASPECT
OF THESE GROUNDS IN THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE RUN BY GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES- TO HELP US ASSIST US-
AS POINTED OUT PREVIOUSLY THERE
VITAL PART OF OUR DISASTROUS.
AND LISTED IN THAT PART OF OUR
CAT PLANNING ACROSS THE BOARD-
BECAUSE OF- THE ITEMS I MENTION
EARLIER. AND EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT IS EXPLICIT ON THE
OVERSIGHT ME ACCESS TO THESE
PROGRAMS- BY CALLAWAY YES
DURING EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY OPERATIONS. OUR
PARTNERS HERE FROM CFA THEY
SERVICE THE EMERGENCY FUNCTIONS
SUPPORT LEAD- WE HAVE THESE
EMERGENCY SUPPORT FUNCTIONS AND
THEY RUN THIS IT'S AN
INTERAGENCY- OUR SUPPORT
FUNCTION FOR US AND IT'S- CALL
THE S. UP ELEVEN. AND OTHER
PRIME RESPONSIBILITIES OF
PROTECTING OUR FOOD SUPPLY AND
AGRICULTURE ANIMALS AND ALSO
PARTICIPATING IS COORDINATED
RESPONSE- GIVEN THE ESCALATION
AND THE DURATION EMERGENCIES
THAT WE'VE HAD. OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH CDFA HAS GROWN- AND- AND
HAS BECOME A STRONGER THAN EVER-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE WE
USE THESE BEFORE AS AS
MENTIONED BETWEEN A COMMAND
CENTERS POINTS OF DISTRIBUTION
IN BASE CAMPS EXCEPT FOR WE
ENDED UP HAVING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE SITES WERE
CODED AS WELL- DURING A RAPID
EXPANSION- TO MEET THE NEED FOR
SUPPLIES TO SUPPORT- THE-
MEDICAL COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE PANDEMIC-
WE WOULD- WE USE THESE SITES AS
WELL TO STORE TRAILERS OF
SUPPLIES FOR US. ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS WHILE WE WERE
DISTRIBUTING THESE- THESE
COMMODITIES ARE THROUGHOUT THE
SITE WE ALSO USE THEM FOR LONG
TERM HOUSING AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WHERE WE BROUGHT IN
EITHER TRAVEL TRAILERS OR
MANUFACTURED HOMES TO ASSIST
THOSE THAT WERE DISPLACED IN
THE GLOUCESTER- RESIDENCES-
DURING THE- DO USUALLY DURING
THE CATASTROPHIC FIRES. A FENCE.
AS MENTIONED- OF. IS AN ISSUE
FOR US AND IT'S PART OF OUR KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING- TAKE PLACE. AS A
SURVIVOR COMING INTO A SITE OR
AS A FIRST RESPONDER USING THE
SITE HAVING ACCESS TO BROADBAND
CAPABILITY SIMPLY MAKES THE
OPERATION EASIER AND ASSIST
THOSE IN AND IN DIRE NEED.
WHETHER IT'S CONTACTING THEIR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS WE'RE
DEALING WITH OUR INSURANCE
CARRIERS- HAVING AFFECTED
INTERNET SERVICE AND SUPPORT IS
A CRITICAL FOR THAT- IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- WE CONDUCTED
ASSESSMENT- WITH- WORKING WITH
CDFA AND DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- TO TALK ABOUT
BROADBAND IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE
FAIRGROUNDS AND THAT EFFORT WAS
SUPPORTED BY A GRANT- AND WE
IDENTIFIED THE STUDY WAS
COMPLETED FOR BY CHICO STATE.
AND THE CARRIERS OF THAT- WE'RE
COOPERATING WITH US THERE SUCH
AS VERIZON AT&T AND ALL THOSE
OF OFFERED TO LOOK AT THOSE
SITES FOR IMPROVEMENT- THEY DID.
A FOR US AND WE PRESENTED THAT
INFORMATION TO THE BROAD BAND-
COUNCIL ON ALL SEVENTY FOUR
FAIRGROUNDS- THAT- I CAN BE
ACTIVATED DURING MERGE
RESPONSE. AND WE FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE UPLOAD AND DOWNLOAD SPEEDS
OF THOSE SITES WERE-
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH UPGRADES- FOR THOSE SITES.
WE MEASURE THEM AND- PUT
TOGETHER THIS COMPREHENSIVE-
BREEDING IN PLAN UP FOR THAT SO
THAT WE COULD- SEE WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO- ENHANCE THE
BROADBAND CAPABILITY- AT THE
SEVENTY FOUR FAIRGROUNDS-
ACCORDINGLY YOU KNOW WE- ARE
ENCOURAGED THE USE OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS OF THE FAIRGROUNDS
OF FOR THAT. AND IT'LL ONLY
HELP AND IMPROVE OUR OPERATIONS
FOR FUTURE OPERATIONS- DOWN THE
ROAD- BEFORE I WRAP UP I WANT
TO DO- REITERATE HOW IMPORTANT
FAIRGROUNDS ARE FOR MERGING
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY. AND I-
THANK THEM FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP I KNOW THIS IS NOT
EASY FOR A PROGRAM MANAGER TO
GIVE UP. ON THEIR SITES- BUT
THEY'RE CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS
AND WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THEIR EFFORTS- WE CAN CRITICS
CONTINUE TO INTEGRATE- CFA AND
THE LOCAL FAIRGROUNDS IN OUR
CATASTROPHIC PLANS. AND OUR
TRAINING EVENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES
TO COLLABORATE THIS AREA- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND ALL. END UP-
OUR DISCUSSION TO OUR PARTNERS
AT SEE. BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANY-
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MAY FRAZIER. SO NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM KEVIN MY- DEPUTY SECRETARY
COLOR PART OF FOOD AND GOOD.
GOVERNOR YOU THE- YES
AFTERNOON- TEARDROP AND RIVAS.
MEMBERS OF THE- MY NAME IS MOSS
ARE A THE DEPUTY SIR OF THE- TO
OF FOOD NAGRA. IN OUR TO THANK
YOU FOR THE ALL TO PRESENT THAT
IN AND FOR TO COMMITTEE THAT
THEY CAN BETTER UNDER. HOW THE
USE OF CAL FAIRGROUND FOR.
RESPONSE IS A KEY COMPONENT OF
EFFECTIVELY MANAGING THAT MANY
UNFORTUNATE SITUATIONS. WE WORK
THROUGH EVERY YEAR. AS A SIDE
NOTE IT DOESN'T BUT YEAH IF I
START TO UP OR THE- STARTS GET
LAW IN MASTER TO ME AND I CAN
SHUT THE BILL OFF I KNOW THAT
YOU CAN BE- BUT IS. MEMBER
AGUILAR. I TALKED BEFORE ABOUT
WORLD. ISSUES NAY SHE KNOWS
WELL MY AREA I'M IN HER
DISTRICT I'M I'M ENOUGH AREA
THAT HAS VERY CONNECTIVITY AND-
SO SOMETIMES WE FROM AND I WAS
IN OR- SIGNAL ABOUT. NOT HAVING
TO ROBUST BROADBAND SIGNAL. SO
BEAR WITH ME AT THAT DOES
HAPPEN IT HAPPENED OR ON IN WEB
MEETING IN BY DURING THE
MORNING. A REAL. SEE PER. THE
AND OVER. OF THE NETWORK ITSELF.
BEARS OTHERS FOR CATA OF. THE
LAW CASH. WHAT WE CALL DISTRICT.
ALSO AND THOSE ARE STILL ENTITY-
THERE'S A- ABOUT HALF MANY OF
THE AS- TOWNIE. AND ARE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT OR NON. OR THAT ARE
THE- AND THEN THERE'S COUPLE OF
CITRUS. FAIRGROUNDS THE RUN BY
NONPROFIT AND THEN ALL CAL EXPO
WE IS THE SAN STAY ENTITIES. IS
THE IMPACTS OF THOSE. BECOME
MORE EXPENSIVE AND CAL. DO
FLOODING WILD ARE. IN THE
RECENT GLOBAL. GRAMPUS ARE
CRITICAL FOR THE BROAD SCOPE
NESSUS ACT. THAT NEED HAPPEN
DURING THE ANSWERED. AFFAIRS
I'VE ALSO BEEN YOU AS HE AND
COOL CENTERS DURING X. WEATHER
EVENTS. BECAUSE OF THE- YET LOW.
THROUGHOUT THIS- WE ARE AND
WILL BE HEAVILY. ON THEM FOR
THIS PURPOSE I'M HOPEFULLY
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
REDUNDANCY- BUT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION NOT PRESENTING HERE
THAT MY COLLEAGUE- YES. MITCH
AS WE- I'M WE DO HAVE QUITE A
BIT OF OVERLAP AND I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE AS MITCH EMPHASIZED A-
MORE TO A- AND EMERGE WERE.
WORK VERY CLOSE TOGETHER AND
VERY WELL WE HAVE A HISTORY OF
DOING THAT AND SO. WITH THAT
HISTORY IN THAT EXPERIENCE WE-
WERE ABLE TO. ACT VERY QUICKLY
AND VERY NIMBLY WHEN
EMERGENCIES DO HAPPEN AND- YOU
KNOW BEHIND THE SCENES WE BOTH
WORK TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER'S
ROLES AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND TO CARRY OUT OUR MISSION SO
I JUST WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT
FOR THE COMMITTEE SO THAT. YOU
KNOW IN CASE OUR PRESENTATIONS
COME OFF AS YOU KNOW SOMEONE TO
PUT IT OF A REDUNDANT ON THAT'S
JUST THE NATURE. YET BUT WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF OVERLAP BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT OVERLAP AND WE
THINK WE COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER
VERY WELL WITH. WHAT OUR
RESPECTIVE FUNCTIONS ARE. MCD'S
MAINLY COURTNEY CENTER BETWEEN
OUR VARIOUS UNITS SPOTS FOR A
MURDER. MAY IN. DEVELOPED OUR
AGENTS FIRST. DEPENDING ON THE
NATURE EMERGENCY EVENT. AND HOW
WE CAN BEST ASSIST THE PRIMARY.
SUCH AS K. YEAH AND CAL FIRE
AND AGENCIES THAT AREN'T IN
THESE. TYPICALLY SEE A POLKA ON
THE SOUL OF THE OF AND- JOHN
FROM THE STATE OF. CENTER BY
PROVIDING EMERGENCY CONTACT
INFORMATION SITEMAPS THE
FAIRGROUNDS LAYOUTS THAT THAT
INCLUDES THE NUMBER OF KITCHENS
BATHROOMS BUILDING SUITABLE FOR
VACUUM WE USE ANIMALS. OF THE
DEPARTMENT ALSO AS A LIAISON
BETWEEN THE FAIR MANAGEMENT
STAFF TO FACILITATE THE MANY
STEPS IT TAKES TO GET THE SOUL
OF THESE OPEN AND READY TO BE
DEPLOYED. IN THE EMERGENCY
ANSWERED AT. THIS OFTEN
INVOLVES LEVERAGING OUR MANY
STAFF HAVE EXTENT EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH. BAPTIST IN
SUPPORT PART WELL- SEDIA IS NOT
SEEN AS A NUMBER WERE. TYPE OF
THE NAY. BUT ACT WITH THE OUR
MISSION TO PROTECT AGRICULTURE
ON THE BASE OF POINT DOES.
HOUSE GIVE INTERVIEWS TO THE
STATE. MOST OF OURS ALL UNDER
IN COMMAND SYSTEM YEAH. REYES
VERY FAMILIAR THE STRUCTURE AND
HOW TO WITH IT SO WE DO OPEN
THREE WHEN THEY TO DEPLOY THEM
TO HELP OUT WITH OTHER MEMBERS
THAT HAPPEN. I'M SERIOUS WORKS
WITH THE PAIR YEAR ROUND HELP
THEM ENSURE CONTINUED OFF.
INCLUDE IN THE MAIN AND IMPROVE
OF THIS. USED DURING. WE HAD
MET PROGRAM ABOUT IS BEEN OF TO
A THE FOR MAINTENANCE NEEDS ON
PARAGRAPH. AND TO MAKE SURE THE
SYSTEM CAN YOU'D DURING THE
MERCHANTS EVENTS. BUT FUNDING
IS FOR ITEMS AS SUMMER PER.
CONSERVE MEASURES WATER IN
ENERGY AND TO BE PREPARED SERVE
AS- A FIRE CAN BUT THAT. CENTER
SHALL. ALL EVERY TO YOU CDFA. A
STATEWIDE SURVEY THE NETWORK
INTEREST. IN THE SURVEY. ARE
USED. PROJECTS FOR AND I.
POTENTIAL BONTA THAT
FAIRGROUNDS USED DURING AN- AND
ONCE A LET ME UP. THAT WE KERRY
AT OUTER PEACHY YEARS AND IT'S
VERY. BECAUSE WE'RE IN A STATE
OF THE MAINTENANCE NEEDS THAT
OF LAW. OUT THE OF RISK THE
HAVE BEEN ABLE BE OF A FOR
THOSE AND IT'S. IMPORTANT THAT
WE CAN THOSE. AND SO THAT WE
CAN SET THE PRIOR. AND THEN
ALSO DO YOU THAT TO INFORM THE-
WHEN THEY DO HAVE MANY OF THEIR
ON WANT MORE INFO. ON HOW
BETTER TO. ALLOCATE SOME OF
THOSE RESOURCES. ANOTHER AREAS
YOU TO WERE ROLLING. RESPONSE
THAT'S IN THE OF MASSIVE
ACTUATION OF KEEP ON THEIR PATH
AND THEIR PAY ALIVE. IS THE CAL
ANIMAL WERE IN. SYSTEM OR THE
CARE IS PRO. BUT PROGRAMS BY
AROUND NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN.
IT ONLY RECENTLY RECEIVED
ONGOING. FUNDING TO SUPPORT
TIME. STAFF TO CARRY OUT THE
FUNCTIONS DURING THE- AND SO I
DO WANT TO THANK THE- FOR
PROVIDING THAT FUNDING. A YEAR
AND A HALF AGO AND WE HAVE PRO
FULLY AUTO. WITH STAFF THERE
WORK ON IT FULL TIME TO ABLE TO
BE A- DURING NUMBER. IN BETWEEN
THE EMERGENCY THE STAFF ALSO
THERE ISN'T A TO. RESPONSE
PLANS AND TO CARRY OUT ON
TRAINING AS WELL AS MAINTAIN.
OF ALL RE. THAT PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED ASSISTANCE DURING
DISASTERS. IF YOU CAN SEE THIS
VERY AND SUMMARIZE OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAIR ROAD.
RESPONSE AND ANSWER MANAGER.
THEIR CRITICAL OF ME ACTIVE NOW.
FOR MULTI AGENTS TO WORK
TOGETHER AND MANAGING DISASTERS.
IN THE IMPACT OF CALIFORNIANS
AFFECTED BY THEM. THE
DEPARTMENT THANKS THE CHIEF
PERSON THERE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THEIR INTEREST IN THIS. AND WE
HOPE THIS HELPS YOU BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEIR IMPORTANCE AND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OR NEED CLARIFICATION
ON ANYTHING I'LL BE HAPPY TO
RESPOND. WE SHOULD ALSO WITHOUT
NEXT WE'RE FROM GEORGE MORRIS
ASSISTANT REGION CHIEF
CALIFORNIA FARM FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION. FROM THE
NORTHERN REGION GEORGE ARE YOU
THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
RODRIGUEZ CHAIRS RIVAS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEES. MY NAME IS
GEORGE MARSHALL THIRD MY
SERVICES SYSTEM REGION SHE OR
CAL FIRE'S NORTHERN REGION AND
MY ROLE IN THE DEPARTMENT IS-
SUPERVISION OF FIELD OPERATIONS
FROM FOR SIX CALIFORNIANS FROM
THE TAHOE BASIN TO THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO AREA. AND INTO THE
BAY AREA- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER TESTIMONY
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF CAL
FIRE- WITH THE USE OF YOUR
GRASS FOR WILDFIRE AND OTHER
EMERGENCY INCIDEN OPERATIONS.
OR NOT I THINK IT BE BENEFICIAL
TO DISCUSS QUICKLY CAL FIRE'S
ROLE IN EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
CALPERS CHARGED WITH FIRE
PREVENTION AND FIRE PROTECTION
THIRTY ONE MILLION ACRES OF
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA FROM
THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE. AND
CONDUCTION CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
FEDERAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIRE SERVICE COUNTERPARTS WE
ARE AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE SERVICE.
CHALFORD DELIVER SERVICE
LOCALLY ACROSS TWO REGIONS IN
TWENTY ONE OPERATIONAL UNITS.
WITH A FLEET OF STRATEGICALLY
PLACED GROUND AND AERIAL
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES WE
MAINTAIN A NETWORK OF
DISPATCHING COORDINATION
CENTERS FOR COMMAND AND CONTROL
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES. AND WE
MAINTAIN SIX ALL HAZARD
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS TO
PROVIDE MAJOR INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT. TECHAU FIRE
UNITS AS NEEDED. I OFFICE THE
STATE FARM ARE. IS ALSO IN A
BOOK. OF SOME BACKGROUND ON
WHILE FIRES AND- THE CLASSIFIED
AS A NEW ATTACK THOSE FIRE THAT
CAN BE CONTAINED WITHIN TWO
EXTENDED ATTACK THE THAT COULD
BE CAN WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AND MAJOR FIRES THOSE WHICH CAN
BE CONTAINED OVER MULTIPLE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIODS. WHEN
EXTEND ATTACKER MAJOR FIRE
DEVELOPS A CONSIDERABLE
FIREFIGHTING FORCES A MASS. TO
ADDRESS THAT EMERGING THREATS
THE INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM IS
UTILIZED TO SCALE TO THE
RESPONSE AND AS THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE INCIDENT INCIDENT
INCREASES SO TOO. DO THE
DEMANDS ON THE COMMAND GENERAL
STAFF. INCIDENT COMMANDERS
DEVELOP A PLAN TO MITIGATE THE
INCIDENT AND THEY PLACE ORDERS
TO EXECUTE THAT PLAN. AS
FIREFIGHTER RESOURCES CONVERGE
ON THE FIRE AREA COMING FROM
ALL CORNERS OF THE STATE FROM
CAL FIRE FEDERAL. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. FIRE DEPARTMENTS
VIA MUTUAL AID. AS THEY ARRIVE
WOULD YOU F. TO RAMP UP TO. THE
FIREFIGHTERS. THIS IS BEEN Y.
TO THIS OVER. ASCENT LOCATION
CAPABLE FOR SO. THE SCHOOL JUST
WHAT BECAUSE ESSENTIAL. THE
FACILITY CAPABLE OF COMEDY
COMMAND OPERATIONS. LOGISTICS
AND FINANCE FUNCTIONS IS
SELECTED IN THE INCIDENT BASS
IS BORN. WE CAN BUILD AN
INCIDENT BASED ON A COLLEGE A
SCHOOL AN OPEN. PARK WHERE
OTHER VACANT OF NESS. A FAIR GO
ARE OFF UTILIZE INSTEAD BASIS.
AS DISCUSSED- EARLIER. AS A LAY
OF THESE. CAN BE LEFT TO
PROCESS. THE VARIOUS. OF AN
INCIDENT BASS A PAVILION THAT'S
NOT USED TO SHOW LIVE. COULD BE
REPURPOSE INTO MOST OF YOUR- A
CARNIVAL. IS INTO A PRE AREA.
AND HALLS ARE. THE HOUSE FIND
AND THE FUND. IN TWENTY FAIR OF
THE BRIDGE EXPANSE THE STATE
USED. AS THE FOUNDATION OF
INCIDENT BASED SUPPORT UP TO
EIGHT THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS FOR
LONG DURATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
FIRE SIEGE. BURKE ROUNDS WERE
UTILIZED FOR THE MANY MANY OF
THE MAJOR FIRE FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIRES EACH INCLUDING THE
OFFICE COMPLEX THE NORTH
COMPLEX CREEK FIRE. AND S. C.
LIGHTNING COMPLEX. SO MANY
ACTIVITIES THAT HAPPENED AN
INCIDENT BASS. REQUIRE AS
SIGNIFICANT LOGISTICAL EFFORT.
MULTIPLE FUNCTIONS WORKING
CONCERT TO ENSURE THE
MANAGEMENT OPERATIONAL
OBJECTIVES OF THE INCIDENT
ACCOMPLISHED ANSWERED BASES
WHERE THE INCIDENT COMMAND POST
THE FOOD UNIT PUBLIC.
INTERAGENCY SUPPORT AND MANY
OTHER FUNCTIONS ARE COLOCATED
DURING AN ANSWER THAT PARKING
FOR HEAVY EQUIPMENT IS EASILY
ACCOMPLISHED A FAIR GROUNDS
WITH FUELING AND GROUND SUPPORT
FUNCTIONS SUPPORTED VERY WELL
THERE. WE WORK WITHIN THE
LIMITATIONS OF EACH SITE AND WE
ADAPT ACCORDINGLY. AND THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL INSPECTS THE FAIRGROUND
FACILITIES USED TO ENSURE FIRE
LIFE SAFETY STANDARDS AND
MITIGATIONS ARE IN PLACE FOR
THE DURATION OF THE EMERGENCY
YESTERDAY AND THIS CRITICAL
WORK ENSURES ONSITE SAFETY OF
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL AND THE
PUBLIC. SOME ELEMENTS OF AN
INCIDENT BASED REQUIRE
SPECIALIZED MOBILE UNITS SUCH
AS MOBILE COMMUNICATION
CENTERS- MOBILE KITCHEN UNITS
AND THEIR SUPPORT TRAILERS
MEDICAL TEAMS BURNING TRAILERS
AND MOBILE GLOBAL INFORMATION.
SYSTEM SUPPORT TRAILERS WHICH
ARE EASILY POSITION AS WELL ON
FAIRGROUNDS. IN TWENTY TWENTY
WE ADAPTED TO THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN OUR INTERNET BASED
LAYOUT DESIGNED TO ACCOMMODATE
ADDITIONAL HAND WASHING
STATIONS HAND SANITIZER
STANCHIONS. AND SOCIALLY
DISTANCE BRIEFLY AND FEEDING.
AREAS WE ALSO MASS TEMP SCREEN
TECH AND WHERE ABLE TO LIVE
STREAM. TO ALLOW FOR REMOTE AND
EVERY FOR. THERE ARE SOME
LIMITS WITH. AND THAT'S USUALLY
BASED ON THE FIRST SCHEDULE AND
FAIR SCHEDULED ARE OFTEN THE
MONTHS WERE CAUGHT FIRES
WILDLAND IS THE MOST ACTIVE.
TWENTY TWENTY MANY THE SITES
FOR USED FOR NINE TEST. AND FOR
EVACUATION CENTERS DURING THE
TWENTY POINT FIRE SIEGE I'M
MORE CALM DISABILITIES THESE
WERE CONCERNED BUT OVERCOME BY
INNOVATIVE AND FLEXIBLE AND SET
DESIGN. WE DO NOT EXPECT FAIR
GROUND OPERATION TO SEIZE WITH
OUR PRESENCE AND WE MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO BE GOOD PARTNERS TO
OUR LOCAL FAIRGROUNDS. AS I
CLOSER LIKE TO CIRCLE BACK TO
THE CENTRAL QUESTION OF THIS
PORTION OF THE HEARING WHICH IS-
OUR FAIRGROUNDS PREPARE TO MEET
THE ONGOING STAGING BASE CAMP
NEEDS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
OPERATIONS. IN GENERAL
FAIRGROUNDS PROVIDE ABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA WEEKLY ORGANIZED AND
CENTRALIZED COMMAND GENERAL
STAFF FUNCTIONS IN SUPPORT OF
MAJOR INCIDENTS. FOR MANY OF
THE SAME REASONS THAT
FAIRGROUNDS ARE VITAL AND
ICONIC COMMUNITY FIXTURES THEY
ARE BENEFICIAL TO FIREFIGHTING
EFFORTS. I WANT TO SAY THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAS
CONDITIONS LINING UP THAT POINT
TO ANOTHER CHALLENGING FIRE
YEAR. IN FAIRGROUNDS WILL PLAY
A LARGE PART IN EIGHTEEN AS A
MITIGATING THAT CHALLENGE. I
THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES
AND CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER TESTIMONY ON THIS TOPIC
AND I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CHIEF NO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
I JUST HAD A QUICK OF. COMMENT
ARE JUST SUGGESTIONS ON- PRE
DEPLOYMENT A CHIEF YOU TALK
ABOUT THE- YOU KNOW I'M MOVING
OF A MOBILE SYSTEMS
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS AROUND
AS- WE SOME OF THESE FARES FOR
EVACUATION PLACES OF STAGING
AREAS SERB BE SAFE TO SAY THAT.
SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS OF THE
STATE WE ALREADY PRE DEPLOYED-
SYSTEMS THERE SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO MOVE AROUND AS MUCH
STUFF THAT OKAY WHERE DO NOT
THIS PROGRAM OR THAT PROGRAM
ALREADY HAVE OF SOME- EQUIPMENT
THEY'RE READY FOR WHAT WE SHOW
UP FOR A BIT DEPENDING WHAT
THE- THE FARES USED. FOR YES
THERE ARE MORE LOOK THROUGH THE
STATE- A PER. WHAT WILL YOU FOR
STATE AREAS FOR PRE APPLY OR
PRE- AND PROD OVER AREAS THAT
WE TRADITIONALLY USE FOR.
ANDERSON WELL. A MAN. IN
QUESTION A ARE CURRENTLY A
COURT TO SEVERAL QUICK. FOR
SITE THE FAIR TO ME OF JUST THE
WHOLE OF WE HAVE EMERGENCY AND
MY- WE- MAY OF YOU KNOW THAT
I'VE- PLAN MOST FIRE. THAN ANY
OUT OF. NOTHING TO BE OF BUT I
AM PROUD OF THE FACT OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER. THE CONGREGATE AT THE
FAIR GROUNDS THE CA COMES TO.
AND JUST DOESN'T OF CINNAMON.
CENTER WHEN FIRE WENT REFER
THROUGH SOME COUNTY WE MOVED
HUNDREDS OF DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED PATIENTS FROM OF THAT
LOCATION TO FAIRGROUNDS IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. AND
EVERYBODY CAME TOGETHER THE
COMMUNITY THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
HELP MOVE OUR PATIENTS IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND WAS AT A
FAIRGROUND. SO WE JUST WANTED
TO. BRING THAT UP BECAUSE I
THINK WE FORGET ABOUT- SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WE SAVE A LOT OF LIVES THAT DAY
AND WE HAD A PLACE FOR THEM TO
GO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR HARD WORK. ENFORCING A
POLICY. OF THE SUMMER. SOMEONE
OR HOW DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION
COM. YEAH THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
TODAY I CHRIS WARD FROM THE
SEVENTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHICH INCLUDES THE DEL MAR
FACILITY THE TWENTY SECOND I
CALL OF THE STRICT- FAIRGROUNDS.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE-
THE DEVELOPMENT IN THE
PARTICIPATION THAT THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING FOR OUR RESPONSES TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT EVOLVING
THAT HAS BEEN YOU KNOW THIS
REALLY HARKENS FOR OUR REGION
BACK TO THE 200-032-0007
WILDFIRES WHEN. THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS WERE RESPONDING TO
SOME OF THEIR YOU KNOW EARLIEST-
MAGNIFIERS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THE STATE OF FOR- THAT WERE
IMPACTING IN IN AND ARE READ.
AND WE ALSO KNOW AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE LONG STANDING
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF MAYBES
FAIRGROUND SOME WONDERING FROM
ANY OF OUR- C. AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES IF YOU COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT.
MAYBE BRINGING TOGETHER IN THIS
MOMENT SORT OF THE- AND WEAVING
IN. BOTH THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE HAVE FOR THIS FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO MODERNIZE AND PROVIDE
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT BUT ALSO
SORT OF MEET. SOME OF THE LONG
STANDING FACILITY CONDITIONS
MEANS THAT WE KNOW MANY OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL FACILITIES. HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN WANTING THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT AS WELL ARE WE
LOOKING AT SORT OF A STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR- REALLY SATISFYING
BOTH NEEDS- FUTURE. EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT MODERNIZATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WIFI BUT ALSO.
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
DEFICIT THAT MANY OF OUR
FAIRGROUNDS FACE. YEAH I CAN GO
AHEAD AND ADDRESS THAT QUESTION
IF THE CHAIR WANTS TO DO THAT
RIGHT NOW. YES GOOD. YEAH YOU
BRING UP AN INTERESTING POINT
BECAUSE WITH THE REVISED AND
GETS NO SECRET THAT THEIR MONEY
SO ASIDE FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PROJECTS IT INCLUDE
FAIRGROUNDS AND JACKSON'S WITH
THE WE GOT A QUESTION EARLIER
THIS WEEKEND I'VE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE INTENT
RIGHT NOW IS TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR OTHER STATE
AGENCY PARTNERS AND ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE AREAS.
AROUND THE STATE WE DON'T WANT
TO DO A ONE SIZE FITS ALL IN
THAT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ASSESS THE NEEDS AND THESE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES BASED ON
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FACTORS SUCH
AS LOCATION DEMOGRAPHICS THE
TYPES OF DISASTERS LIKELY TO
HAPPEN IN ASSESS THE NEEDS OF
WHAT THEY HAVE AND WHAT THEY
MIGHT NEED TO RESPOND TO THAT
AND SO OUR INTENTION AT THIS
FUNDING IS APPROVED. MADE
AVAILABLE IS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO WORK WITH OUR OTHER STATE
AGENCY PARTNERS AND WE'RE GOING
TO DEVELOP A STRATEGIC OUTREACH
STRATEGIES WHERE WE CAN GATHER
THAT INFORMATION AND INTERACT
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CLOSEST
TO THESE FACILITIES THERE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW BEST TO SPEND
NOW TO MAKE THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT IT
CONSERVE THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
FUNCTIONS AS WELL AS- IF IT CAN
BE LEVERAGE FOR OTHER FUNCTIONS
THAT'S HELPFUL TO THE
FAIRGROUNDS. THANK YOU. BY THE
END OF. THE OTHER MEMBERS ARE.
COMMENT SAYING NOT I WANTED TO
THE POLISH YOUR PRESENTATION
AND THANK VERY MUCH FOR YOU DO
AND NOW WILL GO OVER. TO OUR
SIDE. SURE RODRIGUEZ THIS SITE
AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE THE
OTHER PANELISTS FOR FROM THE
FIRST PANEL- THANK YOU GUYS FOR
A FOR INVITING US TODAY TO
PARTICIPATE I WULD APPRECIATE
BEING PART OF THIS DISCUSSION.
MY NAME IS TOM MITCHELL I'M ON
THE CEO ACTUALLY TWENTY ONE
EIGHT DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS ALSO KNOWN
TO OUR COMMUNITY C. MADERA
DISTRICT FAIR. TODAY I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
AFFAIRS ALLIANCE- AS THE VICE
CHAIR AND I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
FEW MINUTES TO GIVE YOU GUYS
SOME INFORMATION A LITTLE QUICK
OVERVIEW OF CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS AND HOW WE SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES. I ONCE I'M
DONE MY COLLEAGUES ARE FROM THE
NORTH AND THE SOUTH END OF THE
STATE I WILL TAKE SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME TO CRY YOU WITH
SOME PECIFICS. ON HOW
FAIRGROUNDS IN THEIR AREAS HAVE
SERVED IN THE PAST- AND WILL
ALSO PRESENT SOME OF THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE SEEN. FIRST HAND
DURING EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS- FIRST- CALIFORNIA
NETWORK AFFAIRS IS MADE UP OF
SEVENTY SEVEN STATE DESIGNATED
FARES- THERE ARE SEVENTY FOUR
PROPERTIES AT BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE THREE. FIGURES OPERATE
WITHOUT PROPERTIES THOSE WOULD
BE THE SECOND AFFAIR THE VALLEY
FAIR AND SCHOOL INVOLVEMENT
FAIR. AND JUST TO KIND OF BREAK
THAT NUMBER DOWN A LITTLE MORE
AS A AS SOME OF THE OTHER
CHANNELS AND TIME. OUT THERE
ARE FIFTY TWO DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS. A
TWENTY TWO COUNTY A NONPROFIT
FIGURES TO CITRUS FAIR. AND OF
COURSE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FAIR ALSO KNOWN AS. CAL EXPO-
OUR CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENT EACH
AND- OF THE- EIGHT. ARE STATE
PROVIDE A C. SOCIAL. AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
OPERATE AS A GATHERING POINT
FOR MANY DIFFERENT CULTURES ARE
COMMUNITIES HOST MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS EVERY YEAR. IN
ADDITION TO OUR ANNUAL FIGURES
ARE CALIFORNIA FAIRGROUNDS ALSO
CLOSE NUMEROUS TRADE SHOWS
EXPOSITIONS RODEOS CRAFT SHOWS
CULTURAL FESTIVALS BANQUETS.
FUNDRAISERS FAMILY REUNIONS
BIRTHDAYS WEDDINGS SCHEMES AND
YET OTHERS BLOCK KOREA'S HORSE
SHOWS. AND LIVESTOCK SHOWS JUST
TO NAME A FEW- HOWEVER AS HAS
BEEN INDICATED AS YOU ALL KNOW
I WE DO SO MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
MANY TIMES WE SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY IN WAYS THAT THEY MAY
NOT EVEN REALIZE ARE POSSIBLE.
UNTILTHE ACTUAL NEED ARISES-
TO JUST. KIND OF BORROWED TERM.
MR MARSHALL BROUGHT I IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET- THERE IS- THE
TERM HAS BEEN DEVELOPED IS THE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY CENTER- IN
EVERY YEAR- FACILITIES ARE
CALLED UPON TO EAT. IN A RARE
INSTANCE ASTRA FOR ITS OWN
THESE DAYS REALLY HAVE MADE A
CALIFORNIA FAIRGROUNDS THE
ORIGINAL COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
CENTER AND WE HAVE TO PERFORM
THESE DUTIES FOR YEARS.
SOMETIMES. WITH AND WITHOUT.
UNDERSTATED INTERFERE OR
INTERFERING IN- BEING PART OF
THAT HI AND MANY TIMES WE SERVE
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FIRST-
AND THEN THE STATE AFTER
AFTERWARDS SO THERE ARE SOME
OBVIOUS EFFORTS. THAT ARE
USUALLY GOOD FOR ABOUT THE
STATE THOSE INCLUDING HOUSING
FOR RIGID PERSONNEL HOUSING FOR
DISPLACED RESIDENTS IN OUR
ANIMALS SCHOOLS ALL OF THE
EMERGENCY EVACUATIONS. FIRE
CAMPS AND WHATNOT- BUT WE DO
ALSO FIND HERSCHEL'S FREQUENTLY
ACTING AS EMERGENCY FOOD
DISTRIBUTION SITES FOR FOOD
BANKS ACTING AS COLLECTION
SITES FOR DONATIONS. EVEN
SERENA HAS WAS BROUGHT OUT AS
STORAGE SPACE FOR OTHER STATE
GENCIES AND LOCAL AGENCIES IN.
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR-
YEAH THERE THERE NEED AS THEY
HAVE THEY MOVE FORWARD WITH
WITH SUPPORTING CALIFORNIANS-
IN QUESTION DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE'VE ALSO FOUND. WE'VE BEEN
CALLED UPON TO HOUSE THE
HOMELESS AS WE BROUGHT UP I
JUST TESTED A VACCINATION SITES
AND ALSO PROVIDE THAT MY SHE
SPACE FOR MEDICAL FACILITIES-
S. IS BEEN MENTIONED AS WELL WE
DO HAVE FARES ARE CURRENTLY.
HOUSING THE UNDOCUMENTED
MIGRANT CHILDREN AND ALSO SOME
OTHER SERVICES THAT ARE HELPING.
LOCAL AGENCIES TO. S. THE FIGHT
HIM HOMELESSNESS WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE SOME FAIR GROUND
SWELL THAT ARE NOW CANCELING
THEIR TWENTY TWENTY ONE FARES
SPECIFICALLY IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THEIR
COULD LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL AS THE STATE THROUGH THIS
TUMULTUOUS TIME. SO NEEDLESS TO
SAY- AT THAT CALIFORNIA'S FAIR
NETWORK ALWAYS STANDS READY TO
SERVICE- AND HAS HAS DONE SO
FOR YEARS- HOWEVER- AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED- THE FIGURES CONSERVE
IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS AND WHAT
WORKS FOR A FAIR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. MAY NOT NECESSARILY
WORK FOR FAIR AND SOME
CALIFORNIA. OR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR THAT MATTER AND
SO QUITE FREQUENTLY WE DO NOT
LOOK AT A COOKIE CUTTER
RESPONSES. BUT WE DO ALWAYS
STAND READY TO SERVE AND DO OUR
BEST TO BE ABLE TO OPEN UP OUR
FACILITIES AT A MOMENT'S NOTICE
IN ORDER TO DO SO WITH THAT
SAID I'M ACTUALLY JUST LIKE TO
PASS THE BATON UP TO EPIC HE
PARTLY. FROM THE CINEMA COUNTY
FAIR. SHE WILL SHARE SOME OF
HER EXPERIENCES IN SERVING AND-
AND THEN AFTER THAT. WE WILL
MOVE TO BY MICHELLE RICHARDS
AND DOWN FROM THE FROM THE OC
FAIR. WILL SHARE SOME OF HER
EXPERIENCES AS WELL I THINK IN
THE OPEN FOR ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THE SPENT.
GREAT SOUNDS GOOD BOB DECHIARA
EITHER. I AM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
YEAR RODRIGUEZ SAID EACH YEAR
RIVAS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE-
COMMITTEE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TODAY I KNOW IT'S A
VERY LIMITED AND YOU ARE ALL
THREE VERY BUSY INDIVIDUALS- MY
NAME IS BECKY BARTLING AND I
HAVE THE VERY INTERESTING
DISTINCTION TO OF OVERSEEING
SEVEN WILDFIRE EVACUATIONS. TWO
WHILE  WAS THE CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER AT THE DEL MAR
FAIRGROUNDS AND FOR AS THE CEO
OF THE CINEMA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS FOR WILDFIRES THAT
HAVE DEVASTATED ARE COUNTY IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS I'M
SPEAKING TODAY SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT WILD WILDFIRE EVACUATIONS
BUT DON'T WANT TO IGNORE. THE
IMPORTANT EFFORTS THAT
FAIRGROUNDS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS. DONE IN SUPPORT
OF ALL THE PANDEMIC. RESPONSE
EFFORTS. YOU'RE GOING TO THE
SITE FOR FUN FAIRS CONSUMERS
SHOWS SPORTING EVENTS CONCERTS
AND MUCH MORE BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT FUNCTION IS TO SERVE
AS EVACUATION CENTERS FOR
NATURAL DISASTERS. WE ARE AT
THE READY WHENEVER DISASTER
STRIKES AND ACTIVATOR
FACILITIES NO MATTER THE TIME
OF DAY. FOR SOME REASON IT'S
ALWAYS TWO O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING BUT IT WOULD BE NICE IF
IT WAS DIFFERENT BUT IT USUALLY
TO- IN THE PAST FOR WILDFIRE
EVACUATIONS I RECEIVED THE
CALL. A LOT DURING THAT TIME TO
OPEN FOR ANIMALS AND PEOPLE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. MY
TEAM. WON MOST OF THESE
OCCASIONS HAVE JUST FINISHED UP
SUPPORTING SOME EVENTS. ALL
RUSHED TO ASSIST WITH THE
EVACUATION. HAVING DONE THIS
NUMEROUS TIMES BEFORE MY TEAM
KNOWS THAT RED CROSS IN COUNTY
SUPPORT WILL NOT BE ON SITE
IMMEDIATELY. AND AS SUCH MOVES
INTO ACTION SETTING UP COMFORT
FACILITIES FOR EVACUEES. IF
YOU'VE EVER BEEN AT AN
EVACUATION SITE WHEN IT'S OPEN
YOU KNOW THAT THE HUNDREDS OF
FOLKS STREAMING AND ARE
FRIGHTENED THEY'RE SCARED THEY
DO NOT KNOW WHETHER THEIR HOME
IS STILL STANDING. HOW THE
ANIMALS ARE THAT THEY'VE LEFT
AT HOME. OR WHETHER. THEY ARE
WHETHER WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THEIR OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
THEY CANNOT CONNECT WITH. SMALL
AMENITY COMMITTEES THAT WE
PROVIDE IMMEDIATELY MAKE A
WORLD OF DIFFERENCE WHEN
THEY'RE START ARRIVING PLACE TO
SIT DOWN WATER COFFEE AND JUST
ASSURANCE THAT WE AT THE
FAIRGROUNDS ARE HERE TO HELP
THEM. SOUNDS TEAMS ARE THE
IMMEDIATE ONSITE SUPPORT IN
THESE EVACUATIONS UNTIL THE
CALVARY COMES. IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ALLOW FIFTEEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FARE SERVED AS
EVACUATION SITES FOR PEOPLE
TWENTY FOUR SERVED AS
EVACUATION SITES FOR ANIMALS
AND TWENTY SERVICE FIRE CAMPS
FOR CALIFORNIA- GRINSTEIN'S
SUPPORT ALL THESE EVACUATIONS
AND DO SO WITH FACILITIES THAT
ARE OLD AND LACKING IN GOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO SUPPORT THE
EVER INCREASING WILDFIRES. THIS
AS YOU KNOW THIS PAST MONDAY
WAS THE BEGINNING OF WILDFIRE
SEASON. AND AS REPORTED THERE
ARE HAVE BEEN HUNDREDS ALREADY
OF WILDFIRES THAT ARE HAPPENING
IT'S A WINDOW INTO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE SUMMER. WHAT
FAIR PRINCE NEEDS ARE GOOD
FACILITIES TO SUPPORT EVACUEES
GENERATORS AND TRANSFER
SWITCHES TO KEEP THE POWER ON
WHEN PGD SHUTS OFF ELECTRICITY
THAT PS PS. UPDATED OR NEW
COOLING SYSTEM TRAILERS HOUSED
ON SITE THAT CAN HOUSE COTS
BLANKETS COMFORT KITS THAT WE
CAN OPEN UP AND HELP PEOPLE
WHEN THEY COME ON STRIKE- RED
CROSS BY THE WAY DID HAVE A
TRACTOR ON SITE TRADER TRACTOR
ON SITE IN OUR FAIRGROUNDS. BUT
IT'S SINCE MOVED THE TRACTOR TO
THE TRAILER TO SACRAMENTO TO
ONCE HOURS AWAY. NOT A QUICK
RESPONSE. I STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT AND ANALYSIS OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ON FAIRGROUNDS
PARTICULAR ONES THAT ARE CALLED
ON ANNUALLY TO SERVICE OF
ACCUSATIONS SITES. SHOULD BE
DONE AND ANNUAL FUNDING MUST BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO FAIR SCHOOL
PLACE MUST WALK WORSE AIR
CONDITIONING ELECTRICAL
UPGRADES. RESTROOM UPGRADES ON
SITE SHOWERS AND THE OTHER
NEEDS THAT SUPPORT EVACUEES. IS
CINEMA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS HAS
BEEN ON THE CDFA LIST FOR MANY
MANY YEARS FOR REQUEST. FOR
FARES REQUESTING IMPROVEMENTS
TO SUPPORT EMERGENCY
EVACUATIONS AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RECEIVE ANY OF A SMALL AMOUNT
OF FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE AND IT WAS. AND
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL CHANGE.
COUNTLESS OTHER FAIRGROUNDS AS
WELL CONTINUED ITS FUNDING. TO
SUPPORT THEIR VACCINATION
EFFORTS. DURING IRAQI. THE
CINEMA COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS HAS A
BUILDING WHERE ACCU ACT
EVACUEES AND PETS OUR HOUSE
TOGETHER. THIS BUILDING IS OLD
AND THE SWAMP COOLERS MARKET
EFFICIENT AT BEST. YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW THIS BUILDING MIGHT
BE AFTER TEN DAYS IN AUGUST
WHICH HAPPENED THIS LAST YEAR.
PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING WITH
INEFFICIENT SWAMP COOLERS WITH
THEIR PETS FOR TEN DAYS. IN THE
FORM OF ACCUSATIONS THAT I'VE
OVERSEEN AND SONOMA COUNTY EACH
TIME WITH PALS TO AVERAGE OF
OVER A THOUSAND HUMAN
ACTIVITIES AND CLOSE TO A
THOUSAND ANIMALS. GRANTS ARE
THE STATE'S EVACUATION SITES
WHERE DO BACKING THESE GO
DURING THESE WILDFIRES. THE
BUTTE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS READ
WHAT ACRE FOR. THE PEDAL FAIR
WHICH FAIRGROUNDS YOU FOR
BROWN'S COUNTY FAIR NO MECHANIC.
NAPA MODERN DOWN MAR ORANGE IN
MANY MORE. THESE FOR GROUNDS
NOT ONLY SIR IF. SITE BUT
PROVIDES THE SAME FOR JUST.
CLOTHING DISTURBING. LOCATION
FOR FREE AND COMPANIES AND
OTHER SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENGAGE WITH VICTIMS OF THE
WILDFIRES. BROWN'S OUR
COMMUNITY ASSETS BUT WE'RE LOW
COMMUNITY LOW COST COMMUNITY
ASSETS AND DO NOT GENERATE
SUBSTANTIAL REVENUES. WE
SURVIVE ON THE REVENUE FROM OUR
EVENTS WHICH OF COURSE HAS BEEN
DEVASTATED SINCE THE CULVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHICH IS WHY
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WORK TO
IMPROVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE AT
THIS FAIR GROUNDS AS WE ARE
VITAL IN THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE BEING AFFECTED AND-
EVACUATION SITES. TO SUMMARIZE
LAST LESSONS LEARNED
FAIRGROUNDS NEED TO HAVE PROPER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADEQUATELY
FACILITATE THE NUMEROUS
EVACUATIONS TWO WORKAROUNDS
THAT HAPPEN EACH YEAR. SECURED
LIGHTING COOLING AND HEATING
SYSTEMS WITH BACK UP GENERATORS
PROPER BATHROOM AND SOUTH
FLOWER SHOWER FACILITIES
UPDATED ADA STANDARDS
ELECTRICAL UPGRADES EMERGENCY
BROADBAND ACCESS AND SCOLDED
PARKING LOTS FOR PEOPLE WHO
SLEEP IN THEIR CARS ON SITE
AMENITIES FOR EVACUEES
TOOTHPASTE CAUGHT TOWELS
ETCETERA. INTO MEDICATION COURT
APPOINTMENT SUCH AS RADIOS
REFERRED TO SOMETIMES AS WALKIE
TALKIES ARE WITH REPEATERS SO
THAT WE CAN CONNECT THROUGHOUT
THE PROPERTY FORKLIFTS TO HELP
LOAD AND OFFLOAD EQUIPMENT FOR
EVACUATIONS AND MUCH MORE LIGHT
TOWERS ETCETERA. YOUR GROUND
HAVE BEEN OPERATING EVACUATION
SITES BUT THE MUCH BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT
AND I'M VERY HAPPY TODAY AND
THANKFUL THAT THIS HEARING IS
HAPPENING AND I'M HOPING THAT
YOU CAN HELP US PROVIDE BETTER
SERVICE TO OUR EVACUEES IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BECKY SO NOW THAT'S FINE WITH
YOUR FROM- MICHELLE RICHARDS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY FAIR SHOWER
EITHER. I AM THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE RODRIGUEZ AND
CHAIR RIVAS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY I'M WONDERING IF I
MIGHT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY SCREEN. WE HAVE A FEW
PHOTOS TO SHARE IS THAT
POSSIBLE. I BELIEVE SO. YES IT
IS. OKAY. ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY REGARDING
THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
FAIRGROUNDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE WITH REGARD TO
EMERGENCY UTILISATION MY NAME
IS MICHELLE RICHARDS I'M THE
CEO OF THE OC FAIR AND EVENT
CENTER IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE THE THIRTY SECOND
DISTRICT OVER CULTURAL
ASSOCIATION AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE MANY
FAIRGROUNDS IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE STATE. OF NOW I'D
LIKE TO BRING IT DOWN TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL THIS IS WHERE THE
ACTION TAKES PLACE AND WHERE
FAIRGROUND STAFF SPRING INTO
ACTION WHEN THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY I'LL SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE ORANGE
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS AND ALSO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING THE OTHER FAIRGROUNDS
IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE
STATE. ON MARCH THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY UNDERAN
EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM THE
GOVERNOR THE OC FAIR AND EVENT
CENTER SHUT DOWN FOR BUSINESS.
AND ONLY ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES
LIKE OUR SECURITY STAFF OUR
MAINTENANCE TEAM WERE LEFT ON
SITE. THE TWENTY TWENTY OC FAIR
WAS FORCED TO CANCEL ALONG WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED LARGE EVENTS
ALREADY SCHEDULED FOR THE REST
OF THE YEAR. AT THE TIME WE ALL
THOUGHT THINGS WOULD BE SHUT
DOWN FOR A FEW WEEKS AND WE ALL
GET BACK TO BUSINESS SHORTLY.
BY JUNE IT WAS OBVIOUS WE HAD A
FULL SCALE CRISIS ON OUR HANDS
SO WE DID WHAT FAIRGROUNDS
TYPICALLY DO DURING EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS. WE REACHED OUT
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITIES.
BEGINNING IN EARLY JUNE AND
CONTINUING UNTIL JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO WE TEAMED UP WITH THE
POWER OF ONE FOUNDATION AND THE
OC FOOD BANK. TO DISTRIBUTE
FARM FRESH MEATS DAIRY PRODUCTS
AND PRODUCE TO AN AVERAGE OF
FIVE THOUSAND VEHICLES EACH
SATURDAY. UTILIZING TWO OF OUR
LARGE PARKING LOTS AND LOTS OF
SOME OF THAT PRETTY SOON CAME
FROM OUR OWN CENTENNIAL FARM.
OUR BOARD MEMBERS VOLUNTEERS
AND SO DID OUR STAFF IT'S WHAT
WE DO BECAUSE WE TOO ARE PART
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE. BY SUMMER THE PANDEMIC
WAS IN FULL FORCE AND WE
PROVIDED TO ADDITIONAL PARKING
LOTS TO WORK WITH THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE TO PROVIDE FREE KOPET
TESTING. THAT CONTINUED UNTIL
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO. IT WAS AN
AMAZING OPERATION AND WE WERE
HAPPY TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. NEAR THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY PARTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY WERE DEVASTATED BY TWO
LARGE WILDFIRES ARE EQUESTRIAN
CENTER SERVES AS A LARGE ANIMAL
EVACUATION SITE AND FROM
OCTOBER TWENTY SIXTH. THROUGH
THE THIRTY FIRST WE HOUSE
TWENTY FIVE COURSES EVACUATED
FROM THE SILVERADO FIRE. NOT
MORE THAN FIVE WEEKS LATER WE
WERE AWAKENED IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT TO ONCE AGAIN RESPOND
TO THE BONFIRE. DECEMBER THIRD
THROUGH THE SEVENTH WE HOUSING
ADDITIONAL TWENTY ONE FOUR SIX.
SINCE MARCH THIRTY FIRST THE OC
FAIR AND EVENT CENTER HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE TO HOST ONE OF THE FIVE
SUPERPIPE VACCINATION SITES IN
OUR COUNTY. THIS HUGE OPERATION
UTILIZES THREE OF OUR LARGEST
PARKING LOTS AND THREE OF OUR
LARGE EXHIBIT BUILDINGS
VACCINATING FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE PER DAY. AGAIN THE OC
FAIR AND EVENT CENTER THE
THIRTY SECOND DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION IS SO
HAPPY THAT WE CAN BE A PART OF
HEALING OUR COMMUNITY AND
MOVING FORWARD FROM THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE DID IT ALL
WITHOUT BEING PAID FOR THE USE
OF OUR FACILITIES BUT THAT'S
JUST OUR STORY. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE SLIDE THIS DETAILS THE
OTHER FAIRS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND THIS YEAR. THAT
HAVE ALSO BEEN CALLED INTO
ACTION DURING DISASTERS WHETHER
THAT BE TO SERVICE FIRE CAMPS-
COALBED RESPONSE SITES ON
ANIMAL EVACUATIONS. EARTHQUAKE
CENTERS EXCEPT DROPPED. OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS
FAIRGROUNDS THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN CALLED
INTO SERVICE DURING EMERGENCIES
AND YOU'LL SEE THIS IS JUST A%
QUICK LAST. BECAUSE BEARS ARE
COMMUNITY BASED EVERY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IS DIFFERENT AND IS
BASED ON WHAT THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY NEEDS AT THE TIME ALL
FARES ARE IMPORTANT TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES NO MATTER WHAT THE
EMERGENCY IS. FIRES EARTHQUAKES
FLOODS PANDEMICS. WE NEED TO
ALWAYS BE IN A STATE OF
READINESS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
SCHEDULE AN EMERGENCY. A VERY
SMALL PORTION OF THE
ACTIVATIONS THAT YOU SEE ON
THIS LIST WERE FUNDED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. BUT MOST EITHER JUST
RECEIVED HARD COST
REIMBURSEMENT FOR STAFFING OR
EQUIPMENT OR RECEIVE NO
REIMBURSEMENT AT ALL. AS IN THE
CASE OF THE- SEAFARERS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE WE REQUEST
REIMBURSEMENT AFTER THE EVENT
FROM LOCAL AGENCIES AT EVEN AT
THE STATE LEVEL BUT IT'S NEVER
EASY AND IT'S OFTEN
UNSUCCESSFUL. AND NOT JUST
COVERS THE REIMBURSED HARD
COSTS LIKE STAFFING AND
EQUIPMENT BUT IT DOES NOT COVER
THE LOSS OF REVENUE FOR THE
RENTAL OF OUR FACILITIES.
FUNDING IS CRITICAL IN ORDER TO
REMAIN IN THAT STATE OF
READINESS FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES MAINTENANCE
AMENITIES LIKE SHOWERS AND FOOD
SERVICE FACILITIES FOR EVACUEES
CRITICAL COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND POWER NEEDS
INCLUDING BACKUP GENERATORS.
FAIRS LIKE THE OC FAIR AND
THOSE ON THE SLICE GENERATE OUR
OWN REVENUE. WE COUNT ON THE
ANNUAL FAIRS AND OTHER EVENTS
THAT WE HOST THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR FOR THAT REVENUE. WHEN WE
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES WE NOT
ONLY INCUR COSTS. BUT OUR
BUILDINGS AND GROUNDS ARE TAKEN
OFF LINE FOR ANY FURTHER
REVENUE GENERATION SUPPORT IS
CRITICAL IF WE ARE TO CONTINUE
USING OUR FAIRGROUNDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSES. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MICHELLE AND I
BELIEVE- TOM YOU JUST WANT TO
ADD SOME LAST COMMENTS. YES SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WANT TO
ECHO SOME OF- BOTH MICHELLE
AND- AND BECKY'S COMMENTS ON.
YOUR FIGURES HAVE HISTORICALLY
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB AND DOING
A LOT WITH A LITTLE. AND SO IN
MANY WAYS- OUR FACILITIES HAVE.
BECOME DEGRADED BECAUSE OF
THAT- THERE WERE TIMES IN THE
PAST WHEN OUR FACILITIES WERE
JUST FINE TO OPERATE AS
EMERGENCY FACILITIES THEY THEY
SERVE EVERYBODY'S NEEDS. BUT
OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE OF THIS
MENTALITY AND DOING A LOT WITH
A LITTLE WE HAVE FOUND THAT OUR
FACILITIES ARE NOW NO LONGER.
UP TO DATE- THEY NO LONGER MEET
THE NEEDS SOME EXAMPLES OF THAT
WOULD BE THAT EVEN HERE DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
FOUND THAT- OUR FACILITY WERE
BEING TURN DOWN FOR USE. BY
SOME OF THE FEDERAL PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE DID NOT HAVE. THE
APPROPRIATE EIGHTY EIGHT-
ACCESSIBLE FACILITIES ALSO OUR
RESTROOMS WE DID NOT RELAX THE
SHOWER FACILITIES THAT ARE NOT
REQUIRED. THE TO ASK ONE OF THE
IRONIES OF THIS IS THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY WHEN THERE IS A
MAJOR. I NEED IN THE STATE
TREASURER OF THE FIRST ENTITIES
THAT ARE REACHED OUT TO- HAS
BEEN SAID YOU KNOW. OUR FAIR
MANAGERS HE OPERATE PRETTY MUCH
ALL CALL BASIS AND YES AS OF
THIS MONDAY- WE ARE NON
WILDFIRE SEASON WHICH MEANS
THAT I FULLY EXPECTS YOU ALSO
MAY RECEIVE A PHONE CALL AT
MIDNIGHT AND WE WILL MAKE
OURSELVES AVAILABLE AND COME
OUT. I THINK ONE THING THAT I
WOULD LIKE OF THE COMMITTEES TO
ALSO UNDERSTAND ABOUT. FUNDING
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IS THAT
BECAUSE OF THE FACT AFFAIRS
WERE UNABLE TO OPERATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND ALSO NOW HERE
AS WE GO INTO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE HAVE FOUND OUT THAT SO
WE HAD TO LAY OFF MUCH OF OUR
STAFF- SO IN THE PAST WHEN THEY
SAY THAT WE DID A LOT WITH A
LITTLE. WE WOULD UTILIZE OUR
OWN STAFF. TO FULFILL A LOT OF
THE NEEDS OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE OH YES IN CAL FIRE AND RED
CROSS AND FOR ANIMAL EVACUATION
SERVICES. WE UTILIZE OUR OWN
STAFF TO FILL THOSE NEEDS. AND
NOW THAT AS WE GO FORWARD WE NO
LONGER HAVE THOSE STAFF MEMBERS
ARE AVAILABLE AND SO WE
STRUGGLE WITH THE ABILITY TO.
POTENTIALLY FILL SOME OF THOSE
NEEDS AS WE MOVE INTO RIGHT
INTO THIS. TERRIBLE FIRE SEASON
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ALSO
AS MICHELLE SAID. WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE NEXT. POSSIBLE
PANDEMIC OR THE NEXT. THE NEXT
NEED WILL BE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO YOU KNOW FOR US
AS FARES- WE DO NEED EMERGENCY
FUNDING IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
BRING OUR FACILITIES BACK ON
LINE. BUT I ALSO THINK ANOTHER
THING THAT'S IMPORTANT HAS BEEN
ADDRESS HERE. BY A COUPLE OF
THE DIFFERENT- PANELISTS YOUR
FIGURES WE ARE FAIR GROUNDS
FIRST AND WE SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AS FAIRGROUNDS. WE
REALLY SERVE IN ANY WAY
POSSIBLE BUT- BUT RIGHT NOW OUR
NEEDS. ARE TO BE ABLE TO
BROUGHT BACK ON LINE THAT TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
AS PLACES FOR GATHERING. AND
KNOWING THAT THAT IN DOING THAT
WE WILL THEN BE ABLE TO SERVE
OUT FOR THE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
SO I ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD FOR
BRINGING UP ONE REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC AND THAT IS
THE- MODERNIZATION AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICIT- IT IS A
BIT OF. A BIT OF AN ITEM THAT A
LOT OF TIMES FAIRS AND DON'T
WANT TO ADDRESS BUT OUR
FACILITIES THE MAJORITY OF OUR
FACILITIES WERE. BUILT IN THE
FIFTIES AND A LOT OF FAIR
GROUNDS HAVE NOT SEEN MAJOR
IMPROVEMENTS SENSE THAT- YOU
KNOW WE MAY HAVE AS AS WE REFER
TO HERE AT THE- MADERA DISTRICT
FAIR. ARE WE MANY TIMES CALL
LIPSTICK ON A PIG WEEK WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF THINGS TO MAKE
THE FAIR TO MAKE THE FACILITIES
LOOK NICE. OUT TO MAKE THEM
USABLE BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE STILL ARE OPERATING WITH
FACILITIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
NOW CHRISTIAN SEVENTY EIGHTY
YEARS OLD AND IN MANY CASES
AFFAIRS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
EVEN OLDER. SO YOU'RE GOING
FORWARD OBVIOUSLY FUNDING IS
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK THAT THE
MOST IPORTANT ASPECT IF I CAN
LEAVE YOU WITH ANYTHING IS
THAT. WE DO STILL STAND READY
TO SERVE AND WE ALWAYS WILL
STAND READY TO SERVE. AND I
THINK THAT- YOU KNOW WE REALLY
APPRECIATE BEING INCLUDED IN
THIS CONVERSATION TODAY AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL OF YOU AS WELL AS TO ALL
OF. THE OTHER PANELISTS WHO
WERE. ALL TODAY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU TO. AND
THANK YOU THE REST OF THE- FOR
YOUR CUSTOMER PURCHASE. NOW
WILL BRING IT BACK TO OUR- THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
ONE THING I WANTED TO SAY JUST
KIND OF BRIEFLY OF. THE FAIR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF RHODE
PROVIDING FOR MORE VALUABLE
RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES TO
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE
TO OUR- FIRST RESPONDERS OUT
THERE. ARE DISTRICTS SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON THE FAIR IN MY
DISTRICT L. A. COUNTY FAIR AS
ITS TRANSITION OUT TO. HOUSING
THE ISSUE WERE HAVING OF THE
BORDER WITH THE MIGRANT
CHILDREN THERE TO REALLY
TRANSFORM ITSELF INTO A- A
COMMUNITY PROVIDE SERVICES AND
RESOURCES FOR THE CHILDREN. NOT
TO MENTION- IN TIMES OF NEED
FOR FIRE EVACUATIONS FOR AND IN
THAT CASE A LOT OF- ANIMALS OUT
THERE- OVERSEE. FUNDING IS A
KEY AS YOU TALKED ABOUT TO
UPGRADE INFRASTRUCTURE. WITHOUT
UPGRADING MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BECOMES. VERY
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THAT.
THE RESOURCE IS THERE TO ASSIST
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS IN THE
TIME INDEED WHEN THEY COME. TO
SET UP CAMPS AND PROVIDE
SERVICES. COM SO WITH THAT
DON'T KNOW HEARD IN. QUESTION
BY ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
THINK OF ARCHER RIVAS YOU HAD A
QUESTION YEAH I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PANELISTS VERY
INFORMATIVE- SPECIALLY THE
SECOND PANEL YOU KNOW AS- AS WE
KNOW IT- THESE EMERGENCIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. OF THE
GROWING THREAT OF WILDFIRES
WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED- BE
BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY- THE NEEDS- AND-
THE CRITICAL- SERVICES- THAT
OUR PROGRAMS. HAVE PROVIDED-
YOU KNOW OUR INCREDIBLE BUT YOU
KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS-
ONGOING IT'S EVOLVING- AND SO
CERTAINLY THIS IS GOING TO BE
AN ON GOING ON A DISCUSSION AS
WE TRY TO DO WHAT WE CAN. TO
ENSURE THAT BACKGROUNDS HAVE
THE RESOURCES AND HAVE THE
SUPPORTS- ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO- OUR ABILITY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NEEDED AT
OUR FAIRGROUNDS ESPECIALLY IN
IN IN IN ALMOST REMOTE AND
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE'S A
REALLY APPRECIATE. ALL OF THE
PANELISTS- MAKING THE TIME FOR
US AND LOOK FORWARD TO- SOME
ENGAGEMENT- IN THE FUTURE. THE
BIGGEST CHECKING SOME REMEMBER
I HAVE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHECK
A CHARTER FROM G. MANAGEMENT. I
THANK YOU ALL OF THE PANELISTS
FOR YOUR INFORMATION ON- ON HOW
THE FARES ARE DOING- HAVING-
BEEN A VETERAN OF THE L. A.
COUNTY FAIR I THINK I ATTENDED
TO. IT'S GONNA BE BAD OVER HALF
A CENTURY AGO AND- AND EVER
SINCE- WE'VE GOT EVERY
SPORADICALLY. BUT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE THERE YOU REALIZE THAT
THE UNDERLYING WATER SYSTEMS
THE SEWER SYSTEMS AND ALL OF
THOSE- ARE ARE ARE HALF A
CENTURY OR MORE. OLD AS WELL.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT EVACUATION
CENTERS AND MASS PEOPLE. THOSE
ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO STAY
UP WITH. AN AYE I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS HOW HOW HAVE THE
FAIR GROUNDS THEMSELVES BEEN
ABLE TO STAY UP WITH THAT OR
ARE THEY JUST KIND OF. PUTTING
PATCHES IN PLACE AND HOPING IT
HOLDS- WE PROBABLY NEED TO
MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
IN THE UNDERLYING. UTILITIES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT IN ORDER
TO KEEP MAINTAINING- THE
ASSISTANCE THAT WE CAN GIVE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY DO EVACUATE.
THAT CORRECT. VENTURA'S YOU
LIKELY THEY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. YES WHOEVER ANSWERED
WITH- I THINK THAT ANYONE OF
THE THREE OF US AS AS FOR
MANAGERS COULD COULD ANSWER
THAT BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT I
BELIEVE THAT- WHILE THE WHILE
YOU'RE FOR STRUCTURES ARE OLD
THEY ARE NOT DILAPIDATED AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO MAKE.
WE'VE DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF
MAINTAINING WHAT WE HAVE. SO
YES OUR INFRASTRUCTURE OLD
HOWEVER THEY ARE WELL
MAINTAINED. AND WE DO WE DO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME A LOT OF
MONEY ON MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURES I HAVE BEEN A
POWER WATER SEWER. A LOT OF
THE- WHAT WEEK SOMETIMES
CONSIDER THE NON SEXY
UNDERGROUND- NOT VISIBLE
UTILITIES- WE DO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT. THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE AT THE
FAIRGROUNDS- SO WHILE THEY GET
WHILE THEY'RE OLD- THEY THEY
ARE NOT IN A CONDITION. THAT WE
LOOK AT THEM FAILING HOWEVER.
THAT SAID. WE ARE BEGINNING TO
COME TO END OF LIFE ON A LOT OF
THOSE TYPES OF FACILITIES AND
THAT USE A NEED THAT WE FORESEE
HAVING THAT MANY FAIRGROUNDS
ACROSS THE STATE. BECAUSE
EVENTUALLY WE ARE GOING TO NEED
TO REPLACE THOSE- PEOPLE ON HIM
SO REALIZE THAT WHEN YOU DO
SOMETHING LIKE SECRETIVE AND
YOU HOUSING DEVELOPMENT OR A
NEW SHOPPING CENTER. THEY
LITERALLY GO THROUGH TEAR OUT
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ALREADY
THERE YOU COULD IN NEW PRODUCT
AND- FOR THE MOST PART. THIS IS
SOLELY IS THAT. WE SEE HERE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. OTHER THAN
THE FAIR. IMMEDIACY FEW OTHER
FISH LIKE SO FARM OPERATE. ARE
REALLY LOOKING AT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S MAYBE
TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS OLD
WHERE SOME OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURES I CAN BE- CAN
BE. RECESSION FOR WATER AND
SEWER CAN BE UPWARDS OF FIFTY
TO SIXTY YEARS OLD SO IT
DEFINITELY IS A CONCERN FOR US.
BUT I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THAT DISTINCTION MADE.
THE SOCIALIZE IT WE DO HAVE ARE
WELL MAINTAINED. GREAT THAT'S
GOOD HERE THANK YOU. OUR TOM
JUST HAD ONE QUICK QUESTION
REGARDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WITH OUR FARES. WOULD YOU
HAPPEN TO HAVE A NUMBER BY
JOHNSON HOW HOW MUCH YOU THINK
IT WOULD COST TO- KINDA HELP-
REGARDING THOSE ISSUES IT
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M JUST CURIOUS BY
CHANCE WOULD YOU KNOW. WELL I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN A NUMBER OF SERVICES HAVE
BEEN DONE CDFA HAS DONE SOME
SURVEYS I'M- ALONG WITH AFFAIRS
EXPOSITIONS. I CAN I WILL TELL
YOU THAT I BELIEVE THAT THOSE
SURVEYS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE I
WOEFULLY UNDERSTATE THE NEEDS
OF THE FAIRGROUNDS- AGAIN WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE FACT THAT MOST
OF OUR FAIR FACILITIES. ARE
AGING ARE WE CAN SOAK UP INTO
AN INDIVIDUAL FACILITY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS RIGHT AWAY AND GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE SEVENTY FOUR.
FARES AND SOME OF THOSE FEARS
HAVE EVEN GREATER NEEDS I'M
ALSO JUST YOU CAN SIZE AND
THAT'S ONLY FOR YOU JUST TO
YOUR- YOUR UTILITY TECHNIQUES
THAT WE ALSO. BUILDINGS COULD
DO NOT HAVE AIR CONDITIONING
THAT AS OF MICHELLE MENTIONED
YOU KNOW WE UTILIZED A LOT OF
SWAMP COOLERS- HAS AS BACK YOU
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE ARE
FINDING OURSELVES IN THE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE. WITH
GENERATOR HOOKUPS WITH PS PS I
HAVE AFFECTING US. ALL ACROSS
THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS AND SO WHILE MANY OF
THOSE ITEMS ARE BEING
ADDRESSED- BY SOME OF THE GRANT
PROGRAMS OF CDFA OFFERS WHICH
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE- THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY. THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO US AT THIS TIME.
IS WOEFULLY LACKING IN BEING
ABLE TO BRING ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES UP TO WHAT. WE CAN
CERTAINLY CURRENT STANDARDS.
THANK YOU TO AND WITHOUT WANNA
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A AROUND
THREE- THE BIKE. ADD ON A BIT I
THINK IT WOULD BE ALL- RUN TO
JUMP UP WHAT TOM MENTIONED
THERE- ACTUALLY DO YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER THAT IS TOM SAID- THESE
NUMBERS DON'T REPRESENT THE
WHOLE ENTIRETY OF WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE OUR SURVEYS. REALLY
LOOK AT WORST OF THE WORST.
THINGS THAT ARE BASICALLY. I'VE
GOT A BILL AND NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED RIGHT AWAY AS A HIGH
PRIORITY- BUT THE LAST SURVEY
THERE WAS AMONGST THE NETWORK
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IDENTIFIES. NEEDS AND THERE
AGAIN JUST TO REITERATE THAT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOESN'T
MAKE EVERYTHING A BRAND NEW
CHRISTINE AND- YOU KNOW LIKE A
BRAND NEW CAR THAT YOU BRING
OFF THE LOT. IT JUST BASICALLY
BRINGS BACK THINGS BACK UP TO
WHAT WE CONSIDER A MINIMAL
FUNCTIONAL LEVEL. IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT TOM MENTIONED
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET OUT AS
GRANTS. IS REALLY ONLY
SCRATCHED. THE SURFACE AND IT'S
BEEN. OUR LAST IT'S ONLY LAST
THAN TWENTY DOLLARS AND
ENTIRETY. ABOUT MILLION CAME
THE GENERAL FUND AD WE GOT
SOME BOND MONEY FROM. SB SIXTY
EIGHT SB. FIVE THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT OF WHAT THAT
SAID ANY OTHER. LAST COMMENTS
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO WITHOUT JUST WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN YOUR
PRESENTATIONS TODAY IT'S KIND
OF GIVING US A AN EYE OPENING
VIEW OF WHAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS
THE STATE WITH OUR FOR GROUNDS
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT YOU DO
DAY IN AND DAY OUT. AND SO WITH
THAT- WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- DID A TIME RESTRAINTS
A PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
LIMITED TO TEN WITNESSES
OPERATOR AND JUST GOING TO YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE IS
ANYONE A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
HAVE NO MORE THAN ONE MINUTE.
ALSO OPERATOR CAN YOU CALL THE
LINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO STEP OUT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
JUST A REMINDER ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO.
WE DO NOW HAVE ONE. WE
HAVE THE WIND AT THIRTEEN POINT
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CHEERS
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOY
STERLING I AM CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RURAL CAUCUS. I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE PANELISTS ESPECIALLY
BECKY BARTLING WHO IS B. AT
PRESENT CEO OF. MY CINEMA
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS. A KEY
TAKEAWAY OF ALL OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT I'VE HEARD IS
THE CRITICAL ROLE OF THE TERROR
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS AS STAGING
AREAS EVACUATION AND RECOVERY
GROUNDS AND IT'S DISABILITIES
FOR LARGE ANIMALS THE FAIR
GROUNDS MUST BE UPGRADED. AS
WHAT I CALL SAFE HAVENS WHERE
YOU KNOW YOU CAN GO IN AN
EMERGENCY FOR POWER CELL
SERVICE HI SPEED PUBLIC SAFETY
GRADE OPEN ACCESS BROADBAND.
WATER DISTRIBUTION AREAS
COOLING AND HEATING STATIONS
EMERGENCY HOUSING SHOWER SHOWER
FACILITIES ET CETERA ET CETERA
ET CETERA ALL OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT
NEEDED TO PROVIDE SUCH
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
WAS OR ANYONE ELSE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS IN QUEUE
MISTER CARE. THANK YOU AND
WE'LL BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE I DON'T THINK OTHERS
ANYONE I DON'T SEE NOBODY HERE
AND- ARE HEARING ROOM OR HERE
PRESENT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
SO WITH THAT. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS FOR JOINING US
TODAY WITHOUT THIS MEANS GERM
THANK YOU.